from the first known special
photographic effects shots in the
execution of Mary Queen of Scots in 1895
to the awesome flying na vi's in Avatar
effects wizards have created imagined
events in make-believe worlds special
effects have dramatically moved from the
real world into the virtual instead of
building models on stages sculpting
creatures with clay blowing stuff up or
sinking it in pools a large numbers of
effects are now using CG techniques flux
is a high-performance general-purpose
system develops head DreamWorks
Animation they're easily riled up here
it's used to achieve animated fluid
simulations such as smoke fire dust
explosions pyroclastic flow and other
digital effects the advances that flux
provides and speed quality set up
flexibility and artistic control through
the use of better algorithms allows
artists greater workflows it's fluid
dynamic simulation have a significant
impact on the cost and quality of
production flux was first used on
monsters vs. aliens and a personal
favorite of mine Puss in Boots for the
development of the flux gas simulation
system the Academy presents the award
for technical achievement to Ronald D
Henderson mr. Henderson DreamWorks crowd
is rowdy I think this is a huge honor
it's kind of a dream come true right up
front I'd like to thank my family my
parents Dean and Sharon Henderson my
wife Debbie use put up with a lot of
late nights and preoccupied weekends my
kids Maci and Riley it is incredibly
motivating to have a career that your
kids also love I'd like to thank
DreamWorks to do management our rocking
head of global production Jill hopper
our CTO Lincoln Wallen the incredible
Jeffrey Katzenberg for creating an
environment DreamWorks that is
challenging and inspirational our head
of R&D Jeff like a man with enough
charisma and optimism for a hundred
software engineers also my my partners
in
FEX development at Studio Jonathan Gibbs
the piece bends a for Kim new south and
our great effects development team flux
has been a pet project of mine for about
five years
but it it could have ended as a pile of
very fast Poisson solver benchmarks
without the creative inspiration of [ __ ]
branch Stein it would have been
completely useless without the
contributions of Michael Clive and Tim
Hoff I would not be standing here
without these three gentlemen thank you
very much you guys they're all here
tonight and finally just a huge thanks
to all of the incredible effects artists
at DreamWorks in particular John yüksel
Brett Miller Jeff buds burg it is it's
amazing to work with these guys every
day I'm I'm really I'm feeling grateful
for the ability to have contributed to
something that has helped these guys in
any way thank you very much